In Ivory Coast, voters overwhelmingly approved a new constitution in a weekend referendum,...
...though opposition groups denounced the turnout figure as fraudulent.
In Brazil, students occupy the University of Brasilia headquarters...
...as a protest against President Temer's...
...plans to cut public spending and reform the educational system.
Pro-government supporters in Venezuela gather around the National Assembly in Caracas,...
...while the opposition judges the responsibility of President Nicolas Maduro...
...in the deep political and economic crisis.
China and Russia displayed a model of a joint development of a long-haul jet....
...to rival giants Boeing and Airbus at the Zhuhai air show.
And finally from the Philippines,...
...President Rodrigo Duterte personally sees off 17 Vietnamese fishermen...
....who trespassed in Philippine waters...
...after ordering their release in a gesture of friendship towards Hanoi.